daniel hast du deinen koffer schon
gepackt
daniel hast du deinen koffer
eingepackt
na
noch nicht
auch nicht
pak bitte deinen koffer
einer halben stunde kommt das taxi
pack bietet einen koffer
so ich habe meinen koffer gepackt
hast du deine sonnenbrille angepackt
die hätte ich vergessen
nein die hätte ich vergessen
wir müssen gehen das taxi wartet vor dem
haus wir müssen gehen
das taxi wartet vor dem haus
lösch bitte das licht und schau nach ob
der herd ausgeschaltet ist und ob die
wasserhähne zu gedreht sind
es bietet das licht und schau nach ob
der herd ausgeschaltet ist und ob die
wasserhähne zu gedreht sind
wir sind spät jetzt müssen wir zuerst
einchecken
wo ist unser check in wir fliegen mit
der fluggesellschaft adler
dort hinein es stehen viele leute an
nein es stehen viele leute an
guten tag bitte geben sie mir ihre
ausweise und ihr flugticket
hier bitte hier bitte bitte stellen sie
die koffer auf die waage
bitte stellen sie die koffer auf die
waage
sie können zwei gepäckstücke mit an bord
nehmen haben sie handgepäck
ja diese tasche und diesen rucksack
perfekt hier sind ihre dokumente
das boarding beginnt in einer halben
stunde im terminal c beim geld 38 gehen
sie schnell zur personenkontrolle
das boarding beginnt in einer halben
stunde im terminal c beim geld 38 gehen
sie schnell zur personenkontrolle
legen sie bitte ihre koffer auf das
laufband
[Musik]
legen sie bitte ihre koffer auf das
laufband
[Musik]
legen sie bitte alles metall auch ihr
portemonnaie ihr handy und ihren gürtel
in diesem korb
legen sie bitte alles metall auch ihr
portemonnaie ihr handy und ihren gürtel
in diesem korb
stock warten sie stoppt warten sie geben
sie bitte ihre arme heben sie bitte ihre
arme öffnen sie bitte ihr handgepäck
öffnen sie bitte ihr handgepäck
geschafft gerade noch rechtzeitig
flug ca 80 45 boarding geöffnet
nehmen sie bitte ihr flugticket und
ihren ausweis in die hand sie können
jetzt einsteigen
nehmen sie bitte ihre flugtickets und
ihren ausweis in die hand sie können
jetzt einsteigen
welche sitznummer hast du
welche sitznummer hast du 15 c und do 15
c und du
ich habe 15 a am fenster
ich bin am korridor ich bin am korridor
daniel kannst du bitte unser handgepäck
in das gepäck ablagefach über den sitzen
legen
daniel kannst du bitte unser handgepäck
in das gepäck ablagefach über den sitzen
legen
auf dem sitzplatz 15b sitzt schon jemand
entschuldigen sie meine freundin und ich
würden gern nebeneinander sitzen
macht es ihnen etwas aus den platz zu
tauschen
sie könnten am fenster oder am korridor
sitzen
natürlich kein problem ich setze mich
ans fenster natürlich kein problem
ich setze mich ans fenster
vielen dank danke schön liebe fluggäste
hören sie bitte zu und schauen sie nach
vorne unsere flugbegleiter führen die
sicherheitsanweisungen vor
[Musik]
liebe fluggäste hören sie bitte zu und
schauen sie nach vorne unsere
flugbegleiter führen die
sicherheitsanweisungen vor
verstauen sie das handgepäck in die
gepäckablage fächer über ihren sitzen
vergewissern sie sich dass diese
geschlossen sind
verstauen sie das handgepäck in die
gepäckablage fächer über ihren sitzen
vergewissern sie sich dass diese
geschlossen sind
angehört
ist während dem start und der landung
obligatorisch
an gurten ist während dem start und der
landung obligatorisch
wir empfehlen ihnen während dem ganzen
flug angegurtet zu bleiben denn es
können immer unerwartete turbulenzen
auftreten
wir empfehlen ihnen während dem ganzen
flug angegurtet zu bleiben denn es
können immer unerwartete turbulenzen
auftreten
sollte der druck in der kabine sinken
fallen automatisch sauerstoffmasken aus
der kabinendecke ziehen sie diese im
notfall über den mund und die nase
sollte der druck in der kabine sinken
fallen automatisch sauerstoffmasken aus
der kabinendecke ziehen sie diese im
notfall über den mund und die nase
unter je
sitz befindet sich eine schwimmweste auf
anweisungen der besatzung ziehen sie die
schwimmweste über den kopf
unter jedem sitz befindet sich eine
schwimmweste auf anweisungen der
besatzung ziehen sie die schwimmweste
über den kopf
beim verlassen des flugzeugs orientieren
sie sich an den lichtern am boden und
suchende nächstgelegenen notausgang
beim verlassen des flugzeugs orientieren
sie sich an den lichtern am boden und
suchende nächstgelegenen notausgang
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit wir
wünschen ihnen nun einen angenehmen flug
guten tag was kann ich ihnen zum trinken
anbieten
ich nehme gerne eine cola
für mich bitte ein bier
hier bitte heute gibt es coole mit reis
und gemüse oder fisch mit kartoffeln und
salat
hier bitte heute gibt es coole mit reis
und gemüse oder fisch mit kartoffeln und
salat
das vegetarische menü ist heute
spaghetti mit tomatensoße und tofu und
dazu eine gebackene auberginen
das vegetarische menü ist heute
spaghetti mit tomatensoße und tofu und
dazu eine gebackene auberginen
ich nehme das vegetarische menü biete
ich nehme das vegetarische menü bitte
und ich hätte gerne den fisch
und ich hätte
gerne den fisch
gerne guten appetit
das war ein angenehmer flug
das war ein angenehmer
flug
wir haben nicht mal verspätung sonst
haben die schläge ja meistens verspätung
haben die schüler meistens verspätung
ja da haben wir glück gehabt es hat
keine turbulenzen gegeben
komm wir gehen zur gepäckausgabe
komm wir gehen
max ausgabe
habt ihr das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal